[Music]
hello and welcome to Sophia Ridge on
Sunday
children pulled out of the rubble
grieving parents two countries with
their infrastructure devastated now
there have been some incredible stories
of survival this weekend after the
earthquakes in turkey and Syria but
sadly many more of heartbreak and
tragedy and more than 28 000 people have
now died but the real figure could be
double that so we'll be talking on the
show about what the UK is doing to help
and whether it's enough
we'll be speaking to the foreign office
Minister Andrew Mitchell on the show
today
following a damning report about the BBC
chairman and a loan to Boris Johnson
will be talking to Labor's Lisa nandi
and will also be joined by the smps John
Nicholson a member of the culture media
and Sport committee who released that
report
also joining us the conservative
adventure to John Redwood as the
conservative Rao over tax cuts
intensifies
and after another appalling few weeks of
violence against women we're going to be
speaking to the activist Patsy Stevenson
now you might remember her face from
being pinned To The Ground by police at
the Sarah everard protest
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
lots to get through on the show today so
we can crack straight on with our first
interview of the morning a little
earlier I spoke to the foreign office
Minister Andrew Mitchell
I want to talk at length about the
earthquake and the deteriorating
situation in turkey and Syria but just
before we get to there
um I just want to speak about the
Parliamentary committee report into the
appointment of BBC chairman Richard
Sharp because the culture media and
Sport committee which approved
disappointment say that he made
significant errors of judgment by
failing to declare his role in
facilitating a loan to Boris Johnson who
was then prime minister obviously went
on to recommend him for the job of BBC
chair do you accept the committee's
findings
well we should be grateful to the
committee this is a senior Committee of
the House of Commons and although I
haven't yet read the report the
headlines are in the public domain I
think I think this is really now a
matter for the BBC
um and also of course the commissioner
for public appointments
um has made clear that they are going to
have a look at it he has recused himself
from the process because I think he
knows Richard Sharp um but someone
appropriate will have a look at that and
then we will see whether there are other
lessons to be learned as you say the
headlines in the public domain uh David
Green the acting chair he said the fact
that Richard Sharp didn't declare his
involvement means there are question
marks about the process he says such a
significant air of judgment meant we
were not in full possession of the facts
when we were required to rule on her
suitability for the role of BBC chair I
mean how can people have faith in the
process if that's what he's saying well
I think Damian green is a very senior
member of the House Commons and what he
and his committee says matters but I
think as I say this is really something
which the public appointments
commissioner must look at and we must
wait wait for his judgment and above all
of course it's a matter for the Judgment
of the BBC I mean some other politicians
Lucy power of the labor party John
Nicholson and the s p they're saying
that Mr Sharp's position is untenable
well I think as I say we shouldn't rush
to judgment on that we should allow this
process to conclude and then in the end
it will be a matter for the BBC of which
he's the chairman to make a final
decision I mean I guess um it matters
doesn't it because of people's trust in
the appointments process for these big
jobs is there a wider lessons to be
learned here about people who've made
large political donations not just to
the conservative party but you know it's
obviously happened with labor in the
past as well about whether they should
be put forward for these big public
appointments well I don't I don't think
the nations of themselves are a feature
which should ban someone from having
such an appointment but the most
important issue is that there should be
full and open transparency and I think
that is at the heart of the questions
that Damien and his committee have
raised so the issues are transparency
rather than the donation yes I think
that's right and or just finally
um you know I remember you know this
time last year you made it very clear
that you lost faith in Boris Johnson as
prime minister
do you think that this is partly an
example of you know Rishi sunak and the
current cabinet having to clear up the
mess that was left by the previous man
in the job
well I think that's something which
people will have different uh views on
what's your idea well I think the key
thing is that what Rishi is doing Rishi
and Jeremy Hunter doing is they are
restoring confidence and the handling by
the government of the British economy
and you can see from the markets and
from the recent economic news that they
are doing a very good job I mean Richard
C Nick also said it was about integrity
as well didn't he restoring faith in the
Integrity of the government yes and I
think the process which we've been
discussing does just that okay now let's
talk um about the earthquake shall we
everyone will have seen the absolute
devastation I mean
it's one of those stories for me it's
very difficult to and I'm sure many of
our viewers it's very difficult just to
witness some of the the destruction the
loss of life that's been happening there
you know the official death toll I think
is 28 000 but of course if you speak to
people on the ground it's very clear
that that is an underestimation
I'm afraid that so uh it is Bleak beyond
belief it is the worst crisis the worst
earthquake that we Face certainly since
Nepal uh probably since Haiti one of the
heartening things is that lessons have
been learned from what happened in Haiti
when the whole thing was a disaster
reinforced by the fact that there was no
proper coordination in the International
Community piled in and the response was
as a result was not uh strong and was
not right this time because turkey and
the body within turkey that handles
these things Arab is is much more
sophisticated and is really well
organized the International Community
has been able to respond and Britain was
one of the first people to contact the
Turkish government ask what we could do
and to respond to the needs that the
Turkish government set out of course
it's not just Southern turkey it's also
Northern Syria which is ungoverned space
it's much more difficult to get help and
relief there and and the response of the
British public through the disasters
emergency committee T appeal is
unprecedented they have raised something
like 53 million pounds in 48 hours the
extraordinary generosity of the public
is uh amazing and outstanding and
heartening and I hope that anyone who
wants to support the the disaster's
emergency committee appeal will do so
this money will be incredibly well spent
through International and respected ngos
through the United Nations and it will
make a real difference and the
government is supporting it too through
taxpayers money through matching the
first five million pounds as well so so
you know this is a great effort but it's
really really needed yeah as you say
it's astonishing the amount of money
that people have
taken raised taken from their pockets
and given to the people who say
desperately need it you say that you are
afraid that the death toll will rise do
you think it could double
I think that the figure that the UN
emergency coordinator has given uh
yesterday when he was in the region of
50 000 is the the right figure I fear
that we are going to see
and of course the situation in Turkey
the security situation also seems to be
deteriorating some Aid agencies having
to pause their work what is happening on
the ground well in Turkey there is good
organization uh and uh Britain sent
immediately 77 search and rescue experts
with the top-notch equipment to help
they arrived uh pretty rapidly they have
four sniffer dogs with them and they
have a team of emergency medical
operatives to assess what else can be
done on the ground in conjunction with
the Turkish authorities so so as far as
turkey is concerned
um we are I think doing what is required
two flights took off last night to help
one from RAF Bryce Norton in Britain one
from our stores in Dubai taking tents
and blankets into turkey and much of
that is of course is Bound for Syria it
is in Syria that the International
Community is far more stretched we were
able to get through the one Crossing
that is open for the UN but that
Crossing two was badly damaged in the
earthquake and because of the Russian
veto the U.N cannot use the other three
Crossings out of turkey into Syria so so
it is it is in in Syria that the real uh
problems lie we were able to react
faster because the white helmets which
were the Civil Defense group during the
war they are the responders the First
Responders in Syria and they were able
to uh get get in there and try and help
people out from under the rubble rescue
people and we supported them immediately
with uh some money some more money 24
hours later and that will help them put
fuel in their cars rent and hire
equipment uh provide for blankets and
local stores and help the people there
who as I say because there's no
infrastructure and it's ungoverned space
are in very deep Jeopardy and of course
the temperature last night was minus
five degrees in the region I mean you
can't imagine can you with the
infrastructure as you say just crumbling
and temperatures at that level and you
talk about the situation in Syria being
much more complicated obviously you know
Assad is a dictator he's murdered his
own people we obviously don't have a
diplomatic relationship with him does
that make it more difficult well it
doesn't in these circumstances because
we negotiate with the Syrian authorities
through the United Nations and as I said
Martin Griffiths is on the ground there
he's he's a Brit he's the senior British
official at the United Nations and he's
in charge of the United Nations relief
effort and having him there as a voice
for the International Community makes
our position with the Syrian government
extremely strong so the difficulty is
because the devastation of the country
already because of the years of Civil
War and I have to note that you know the
latest figures show that our Aid
spending in Syria halved and we spent
181 million in 2020 and 91 million in
2021 was that the right thing to do well
you know if you look at the amount of
money that Britain has spent supporting
the the victims of the war the syrians
who've had to move and actually half of
Syria was on the move both to the four
countries around Syria but also
internally displaced and of course a
million of them across into Europe now
throughout that time Britain supported
the Syrian
um displaced people the Syrian refugees
we're still supporting them but the
money's gone down we did we did more for
those refugees than the whole of the
rest of the European Union put together
in terms of support and financial uh
support for the rescue uh efforts
um but but as far as Syria is concerned
it's not really about money we have
provided the funds that were needed for
the white helmets the although the
budget as you as you imply is under
considerable stress when it comes to
humanitarian work we have some
flexibility the point is my point is
that the situation is worse in Syria not
just because of the earthquake but
because of the infrastructure the
hospitals already creaking the country
devastated because of years of war at a
time when we have cut halves the amount
of Aid we're spending yes as I said the
budget is is is under very considerable
stress but we are still spending a great
deal of money there not far short of 200
million pounds so we're doing what we
can and we are having a big effect on
the ground and it is partly because of
the work we do through International
ngos as well as through the United
Nations that we know what's happening on
the ground there and we are therefore
able to ensure that British help really
gets through to those who need it I want
to talk a little bit about the aid
budget as well I know that you over your
career have been someone who's been a
big proponent about the importance of
international Aid of course we should
see that cut our Aid budget from 0.7 of
GDP to 0.5 back in 21 That was supposed
to last for three years so will it go
back up to 0.7 next year
well it will go back up to 0.7 when the
two fiscal tests that were set down by
Rishi and confirmed by parliament are
met I can't tell you precisely when that
will be because it's not clear how
quickly the economy is going to recover
the economy has suffered significantly
from Putin's illegal war in Ukraine and
also of course from the aftermath of
covid so I can't give you an answer to
that but what I can tell you is that my
job is to try and make sure that we have
multipliers which augment the money that
we can use and we are doing that as fast
as we possibly can and also that we made
our case to the treasury one of the
problems for the budget is that we meet
the cost of the first year of Ukrainian
refugees who have sought sanctuary in
Britain that's perfectly proper it's
part of the use that of the aid budget
as as defined but we made our case to
the treasury and the treasury did manage
to find an extra two and a half billion
pounds for of taxpayers money so we're
spending it about 0.55 now but we will
get back to 0.7 as soon as the fiscal
tests are met and the economic
circumstances are loud you obviously
can't tell us when that will be I just
want to have a look at what you said at
the time the aid budget was cut you said
this you said
no one should be any any doubt about the
damage these huge humanitarian Cuts have
done to the world's poorest and to the
reputation and effectiveness of British
leadership that's what you said in
October 2021 what I mean what happened
to that Andrew Mitchell
that Andrew Mitchell is now doing his
very best to ensure that we mitigate the
huge humanitarian Cuts in the way that I
describe by finding these multipliers
for example some people might say that
you've sold out on your principles or
any government job let me explain why I
don't think that's true so we're using
these multipliers to find extra money an
example would be when I was in the Horn
of Africa where we have just staved off
a famine this year uh last year
um we were able to do some co-financing
with other countries which increased the
amount of money that was brought to bear
on that crisis so I'm looking at ways of
mitigating the humanitarian effects and
in terms of the reputation and
effectiveness of British leadership we
are on the case I'm hoping to make sure
that the merger with the foreign office
of diffid works better and the foreign
secretary and I are agreed on a number
of measures which I hope will be
announced in the integrated review which
will help address that very point no I
can't help but think you know whether it
ever crosses your mind that they've
given you this job in government because
you'll be less trouble for them as a
government Minister than on the back
benches you know if you were on the back
benches right now I kind of think that
you'd be on the airwaves saying look
this is just why we need to restore the
aid budget that says why we need to help
the poorest countries in the world and
yes the economic situation is difficult
but that's exactly why we should be
spending more in Aid because of course
the people who suffer when Global
inflation is the highest are the very
poorest well in terms of what I would be
saying I am obviously governed by
Collective responsibility and uh but
Collective responsibility is not
retrospective and I'm doing my very best
to make the system work and you know if
you're a politician you always have to
decide whether or not you are better off
on the outside of the tent trying to do
what you can by shouting from the
sidelines or whether it is better to get
inside and try and improve the situation
and I'm doing the latter there's a lot
of Focus right now on whether the
ministry of Defense budget should
increase partly of course because war in
Ukraine in the Sunday Times today the
they say the defense secretary is
demanding an extra 10 billion pounds
over the next two years are you lobbying
in a similar way for the aid budget
well as I say the fiscal tests will need
to be met for us to go back to 0.7 but
by finding other ways of increasing the
funding we are doing every thing we can
to compensate for that diminution and
you may rest assured I make the case for
the development Budget on every occasion
as far as far as the defense budget is
concerned
um Jeremy Hunt made significant
announcements during the Autumn
statement we are I think one of the only
uh
NATO countries spending two percent of
our gni on defense that is absolutely
necessary the war in Ukraine has shown
what a dangerous world we live in and I
think the government has stepped up by
producing this extra money and we are
the leading NATO country in Europe and I
think we will see in the integrative
review refresh which is likely to be
announced in March that Britain is
absolutely focused both on stopping the
Russian aggression and supporting the
ukrainians and making sure that our
defense is fit for purpose now another
news today the U.S has shut down an
unidentified cylindrical object over
Canada now we don't have more details
about what that is but of course it
comes off the back of the so-called
Chinese spy balloon that was shot down
over the US How concerned should we be
about the role of China
well I think we need to get to the
bottom of this uh transparency is most
important we need to find out exactly
what's been going on what these objects
in the air are doing what their purpose
is and then we will be able to reach a
judgment I mean I think it's quite clear
that both Canada and the United States
have met their obligations to their
citizens and intercepting them and
destroying them and once we've seen what
was actually involved in the technology
we'll be able to make a judgment about
that of course some of your colleagues
on the conservative benches have some
real concerns about China and about the
influencer Alicia Cairns for example on
this program last week the chair of the
Foreign Affairs select committee told me
that I should delete tiktok for my phone
because of Chinese capability do you
think she's got a point
well I don't know I'm afraid I'm a bit
of an analog politician in a digital age
but uh I think it's easier I think I
think that what Alicia says about uh
China is extremely important she chairs
the Foreign Affairs select committee and
many of my colleagues and friends like
Ian Duncan Smith former leader of the
party have been very clear about this
what I would say from the point of view
of the foreign office and the government
is we do have to have a relationship
with China we can't just cut it all off
because otherwise if you don't talk to
them we won't make any progress at all
and we want to try and make the Chinese
government more receptive too and
involved in the International System and
bring them in it's a very long-term
project but we can't just cut off all
relations with China but we have to
stand up for our values both here and
abroad against many of the things that
China does of which we do not approve we
have been sending the maid as well 50
million pounds in 2021 should we be
doing that well I was very surprised to
see this because in 2010 the first thing
I did when the Coalition arrived in
government was to stop all Aid for China
there may be a case occasionally for
some joint technical assistance to be
deployed but we shouldn't be giving Aid
to China and we're looking to make sure
that that Aid is best spent oh really so
you think that actually going forward
that 50 million pounds is not going to
happen again well I think there will
have to be a very strong case indeed and
it would have to be an open and public
case if we'd spend Aid money in China it
could be better spent in other countries
well that is that is my starting point
yes and then just finally we're going to
be talking to your colleague John
Redwood on the program a little uh later
on now we know of course at you know Liz
truss Ally who would like to see tax
cuts on the budget next month do you
think now's the right time to cut taxes
Well we'd all like to see uh tax cuts uh
we're a tax cutting party and I'd served
with John in the House of Commons on and
off since 1987 when we were both first
elected he makes a very strong point
about the importance of tax cuts for the
economy but you know in the end if we
make tax cuts which are not properly
funded it's merely it's borrowing and
it's taxation deferred for the the Next
Generation and you know many of us are
very concerned about intergenerational
unfairness in Britain the position of
our children and indeed our
grandchildren so so I think tax cuts are
very important but they've got to be
done at the right time and I think that
the philosophy and argument that the
chancellor of the exchequer has set out
is absolutely right we will get them
when we can but I think at the moment
it's extremely difficult to justify them
I guess the argument for those on the
John Redwood side is that actually tax
cuts sort of pay for themselves because
they boost growth they boost investment
in the UK do you think there's a point
there well there is a bit of that but I
think the much more important point is
that the chance of the ex-jacker has to
take a judgment about when is the right
time to do it and when we can afford it
and he set out the arguments very
clearly in the Autumn statement that now
is not the time to do that okay thank
you very much indeed thank you
Andrew Mitchell there well we'll talk to
John Redwood a little bit later on the
program uh makes me feel that perhaps
there might be a difference of opinion
shall we say on the merits or otherwise
of tax cuts from him
time now to get Labor's take though on
some of the big stories around uh today
uh whether it is the earthquake in Syria
or of course that report by the culture
and media select committee into Richard
champ we're joined Now by Lisa nandi the
Shadows Secretary of State for leveling
up housing and communities thank you
very much for being with us and I just
want to start with the report by the
dcms committee they say the Richard
chart made significant errors of
judgment in failing to declare his
involvement in facilitating a loan to
Boris Johnson who of course gave him
that job a few weeks later what's your
reaction to the report
it's a really serious development and it
makes Richard Sharp's position
increasingly untenable the government
has relied on the defense that the dcms
the culture media and Sports Select
Committee approved this appointment but
the culture medium support committee
today is saying that actually had they
known about this it would have been a
very different situation this
information was not disclosed to them
prior to approving that appointment
increasingly the circumstances around
the relationship between the
conservative prime minister Boris
Johnson and Richard Sharp is looking in
more and more murky and I think his
position is becoming increasingly
untenable as a result you say his
position is increasingly untenable we
speak to Andrew Mitchell earlier who
said that effectively this is a matter
for the BBC although the public
appointments commissioner is also
looking into it is that right
I I think this is a something that has
far a wider reaching implications across
um Society because the BBC is a National
Treasure it's a part of our culture it
is something that is supported by people
lots of people across this country
paying money into the license fee that's
a system that we absolutely support but
it means that rightly and understandably
the BBC has helped a very high standards
and when you have the BBC being pulled
into an increasingly murky situation and
ongoing
um reports of conservative sleaze and
corruption that's a very serious thing
indeed and I think it's becoming more
and more difficult to see how Richard
Sharp can continue in that role so you
saying he should resign is that what
you're saying
well there is there is there is a report
that is due from the BBC they're
reviewing this matter at the moment I
think it's right that we give the BBC
time to investigate this and to report
on it but I think today's developments
are incredibly serious and for for
several weeks now the government has
been saying that Parliament had approved
this position well Parliament is now
saying through the culture media and
Sports Select Committee that had they
known about this relationship it would
have been a very different matter and
when that report is published I think we
need to know whether you know there is
any defense of that the reasons for
withholding that information from
Parliament and therefore from the public
and if there isn't a defense I think
it's difficult to see how Richard Sharp
could possibly continue in the position
that he's in given the far-reaching
implications for the reputation of the
BBC and the implications for uh trust in
government and Trust in journalism
now you have used the word murky so I do
just want to put richer Sharp's
statement across at this point because
he's said that he regrets and apologizes
for not giving the full information to
the committee but he does say that he
believes that he acted in good faith and
that he proactively briefed the cabinet
secretary the other point that I want to
make is that you know some people might
be listening to this thinking look you
only got a problem with this if it's
conservative supporters or conservative
donors who are in positions of power at
the BBC you know whether it's James
Pannell Gavin Davis Greg Dyke they all
had affiliations with labor and jobs at
the BBC so is it just the politics that
you don't like here
I don't think there was ever a
suggestion that James Pennell
um or any of the other names that you
mentioned facilitated personal loans for
the Prime Minister while the appointment
process was ongoing and then withheld
that information from Parliament at a
pre-scrutiny committee session that was
designed exactly to unearth these sorts
of relationships I don't accept that
that accusation at all I think that the
impartiality and integrity of the BBC
matters I'm a strong supporter and
always have been of the BBC and the fact
that it's publicly funded through the
license fee I think it's one of the
great strengths that Britain has not
least because I just heard your
interview with Andrew Mitchell you're
talking about the increasingly unstable
situation across the world increasingly
aggressive behavior by China the BBC
World Service and other news outlets is
a light on the hill for people all over
the world precisely because it is paid
for and funded by millions of people
across this country and its Integrity
matters and that's why this matters so
much not because it's a conservative
appointment not because it's
um now mad in allegations of
conservative sleeves but because it's
being pulled into what is a very
untenable position around this
government and that's not acceptable
um Andrew Mitchell said that we should
look at whether lessons could be learned
from this do you think in the future it
would be helpful if for example people
who'd made donations to political
parties were banned from public
appointments such as this
well I mean there's a there's a huge you
know much bigger debate around donations
to political parties for my part I
represent a party that is funded by
um millions of people across this
country who put their hands into their
pockets every week and pay small sums in
order to fund us I'm very proud to do
that I think it's the cleanest money in
British politics and I actually think
the answer to this is not
um about the funding of political
parties I think the answer to this is
that those of us in public life have to
behave with integrity and decency and if
we don't not only ought there to be
robust
standards that are upheld and we ought
not to be able to continue in public
life but also that we ought to face the
electorate at The Ballot Box so that
they can make a judgment we've had five
years and well four years now of this
conservative government mad in
accusations ongoing accusations of
cronyism and sleaze some of which have
been proven and I can't wait for the
general election because I think that
this is really degrading every part of
our political system our journalism
trust in our institutions and I think
profoundly this needs to change okay
um just wanted to point out again from
Richard Sharp's statement he says that
he didn't facilitate an introduction
between Boris Johnson and Mr Blythe and
he wasn't involved in the arrangement of
the loan I'm really Keen to talk as well
about the other story that we've been
covering a lot on Sky News which is the
devastating earthquake in turkey and
Syria I mean it honestly it's just
mind-boggling isn't it what we are
seeing unfolding before our eyes now we
know that Syria in particular of course
has been particularly badly hits because
of the devastation that that country was
already facing UK Aid to Syria halved
between 2020 and 2021 if labor wins the
next election will you immediately
restore a the UK Aid budget to 0.7 of
GDP
we can't make commitments to immediately
start funding
our priorities in government the reason
that we can't do that is because we're
likely to inherit the worst economic
situation since the second world war
because of a decade of Tory
mismanagement of the economy I'm
standing here today in Nottingham where
local government leaders are gathering
from across the country that's one of
the messages that I'll be giving to them
today and actually they know it because
right across the country we've seen cut
after cut after cut a consequence of the
fact that we've got low or no growth in
this country our priority is going to be
to get the economy growing by
transferring power out of Westminster
and Whitehall two local leaders and
Business Leaders in our community so
they can start making our economy work
again and as soon as it's practically
possible we will restore the 0.7
commitment we we believe that that is
absolutely essential not just to helping
with the appalling situation in Syria
and in turkey that we're seeing
unfolding on our screens but also to
safeguarding Britain's interests it's
not in Britain's interests to retreat
from the world we used to lead the world
over the last 10 years we've started to
leave it that will reverse under a labor
government but we when we make promises
your viewers should know that we will be
sure that we can keep them
so you want to restore the path to 0.7
as soon as possible I mean it's
basically the same position as the
conservatives then isn't it
well I mean I don't think frankly that
the conservatives have any intention of
doing so Boris Johnson abolished well
they've said that they will they've said
that they will store it when fiscal
circumstances allow which is exactly the
same position as labor
well and credit to Andrew Mitchell who
is just on your program because it was
thanks in part to the uh noise that was
created by Him and other conservative
backbenchers as well as the labor party
that the government felt compelled to
make that commitment but they had to be
dragged Kicking and Screaming to do it
the difference between us and them is
that we believe that by going out and
playing a leading role in the world in
looking to the world beyond our Shores
we helped to safeguard Britain's
interests it's why we've said to the
government that they've been far too
complacent about the rise of China
they've been far too unfocused about
growing Russian aggression on our
doorstep and it's why just a moment ago
you had Andrew Mitchell a ministering
government saying that the government is
now having to revise their 10-year
strategy for how we relate to the rest
of the world only a year after they
published it I'm glad that they're doing
it but every single time this government
has to be drug Kicking and Screaming to
recognize that what happened beyond our
Shores matters deeply to the interests
of the British people our record in
government shows otherwise and when
we're in government again we will help
to safeguard Britain's interests by
reaching out to the world and leading
not leaving
just finally you are talking about
transferring power away from Westminster
to local communities this weekend I
guess my real question is you know
if you've had dealings with your local
councils I'm sure lots of people
watching this program will have why on
Earth would you think that local
authorities are any better at dealing
with these issues than Westminster
well because if you look at the example
from across the country whether it's in
Telford where the labor Council has gone
out and secured millions of pounds worth
of investment to create jobs and to
skill up their young people to be able
to get those jobs whether it's Tracy
braben the mayor of West Yorkshire who
has recently secured secured a thousand
jobs for Bradford by flying across the
world and explaining the benefits of
investing in her region these are
leaders who know their communities well
who are better placed to be able to
drive economic growth and build thriving
local economies and instead what we've
got is the Absurd situation where
they're going cap in hands to
Westminster and Whitehall asking for
small powers and resources in order to
do the things they know that works today
we've released the dossier that shows
that this government is over
micromanaging to such an extent that
they're even telling local authorities
when and how to remove chewing gum from
park benches we think this country can
do far far better than that and that's
why we say that we're going to get the
economy growing in every part of Britain
so that young people in every Community
know that they can have the choices and
chances that they deserve
thank you very much indeed Lisa and Andy
there
they're pretty strong I thought on the
appointment of Richard Sharp saying that
his position in her view is untenable of
course I gave you his reaction to that
as well his response and also it's
saying that both labor and the
conservatives as we've learned on the
program unable to commit immediately to
restoring that Aid budget Target of 0.7
of GDP despite the devastation that
we've seen in turkey and Syria still
come on the program this morning we are
going to be hearing a little bit more
from the S P's John Nicholson he of
course is on that committee that looked
into the appointment of the BBC chairman
we'll also be speaking to John redwoods
it'd be interesting to hear a
conservative backbend show he's got some
interesting views on tax cuts and what
the chancellor should be doing in the
budget next month plus we'll get some
immediate reaction from our political
correspondent Liz Bates who's watching
all around interviews she's not on the
screen today because she's going to be
in the studio which is good news for us
so we're going to be talking to Liz on
the program in the take that's at 9 30.
[Music]
well let's get more now on the loan that
keeps attracting interest our show
producer Steve very happy uh with that a
particular bit of scripting there now
the chairman of the BBC Richard Sharp As
we've been discussing is under renewed
pressure over claims he was involved in
helping to facilitate a loan for Boris
Johnson before being made to the chair
of the corporation and the commons
digital culture media and support
committee says he made significant
errors of judgment when failing to
declare his role and he should reflect
on the potential damage caused to trust
in the BBC well I've been speaking to
the S P's John Nicholson who's on the
committee
just talk us through the findings of
this report
well you've read the report the report
is I think uh pretty uh brutal what we
found is that Richard Sharp the BBC
chair has broken the rules the rules
quite clearly say that if you apply for
a public service job like this you've
got to be completely open about any
conflict of interest now Mr Sharp
facilitated an enormous 800 000 pound
loan to Boris Johnson the then prime
minister and it was Boris Johnson who
appointed Richard Sharp As BBC chair so
clearly that's a conflict of interest he
didn't tell his interview panel and he
didn't tell us as MPS who are then asked
to consider his appointment and um when
he appeared before us last week he
didn't seem to think that he'd done
anything wrong which I found perplexing
because clearly he broke the rules we
knew he was a big Tory party donor we
knew he'd given 400 000 pounds to the
Tories that's not against the rules
which is I was going to say that's not
against the rules and we knew about that
I think it's wrong I don't think you
should be giving huge amounts of money
and then getting a plum job from the
people you've given money to think
that's wrong but as you say it's not
against the rules but we didn't know
anything about this huge loan to Boris
Johnson
I want to just come in now with Mr
Sharp's uh statement because I think
it's important of course to put his
point of view across as well he said
that he did breathe with cabinet
secretary about the appointment and that
he was never involved in the arrangement
of a loan between Mr Blythe and Mr
Johnson so let's just have a look at a
statement now uh he says uh Mr Sharp
appreciates that there was information
that the committee felt that it should
have been made aware of in his
pre-appointment hearing your point he
regrets this and apologizes and then he
goes on to say it was in seeking at the
time to ensure that the rules were
followed and in the belief that this had
been achieved that Mr Sharp acted in
good faith in the way he did that's the
defense well that's a load of old
flannel isn't it I mean that doesn't
really mean anything at all he
appreciates the committee's upset uh why
is he not sorry uh he had a long session
with us where he could have said he
could have put his hands up he could
have showed a bit of humility I mean he
does apologize to be fair he says he
regrets this and apologize he could have
apologized when he was in front of the
committee he's apologizing no because he
sees how brutal the report is and he's
fighting for his job but I think one of
the problems as well was just his
General approach to the committee when
he appeared before MPS cross-party
committee he was just so haughty and
entitled and if I've been him and I'd
realize that I'd done something as badly
wrong as he had done I think I'd have
apologized on the spot and said I'd made
a mistake and he didn't do that he sat
before us for the whole hearing and
failed to apologize at any point
uh now you I just want to say you're
obviously your committee has a really
important role in accepting the
appointment of the chair and at the time
you said you didn't know all the facts I
just want to have a look at what your
committee acting chair Damien green had
to say conservative Damian green he said
such a significant air of judgment meant
that we were not in the full possession
of the facts when we were required to
rule on his suitability for the role of
BBC chair if you knew then what you know
now do you think the appointment would
have gone through I can't speak for
other members of the committee because
we didn't know what we know then what we
we know know but it's it's absolutely
clear that when he filled out the
application form in fact I read out the
application form rules to him that he
had to sign to say that there was
nothing in his past that could
potentially cause embarrassment either
to him or to the BBC clearly the BBC is
enormously embarrassed by this and BBC
staff I know because they're writing to
to meet huge numbers BBC staff are very
upset about this they're upset about the
way that he's behaved as chair
because he he imposed himself on a board
to choose the the head of BBC News and
current affairs he's not a journalist he
shouldn't be doing that so they're
worried about political interference and
I think for BBC staff now they've lost
confidence in him so it's difficult to
see how he can carry on how many have
written to you then roughly
scores scores of BBC staff written to
you and would you have come to a
different conclusion I know you can't
talk about members of the committee but
would you have come to a different
conclusion yourself well
my my view always is that people who've
given huge donations to political
parties should not be appointed to
Public Service roles that is my ongoing
View and I think pure starmer now if he
wants to clean up politics when he
becomes prime minister if he becomes
prime minister I think he should now say
that anybody who's given a large
donation to labor or any other political
party should not get a public service
Rule and that he will not give big
public service jobs to donors to the
labor party because this is key isn't it
because a lot of people will be looking
at this and say look you guys only kick
up a fast when it's a conservative
supporter who gets a job well I think I
think they say that to the labor party
they don't say that to my party if you
look at you know James Pannell Gavin
Davis Greg Dyke they all had
affiliations to labor they all went into
top jobs in the BBC some people might
think well maybe this is a bit of a
rebalancing well I don't think that I
think it's wrong for any party to
receive large amounts of money and for
the party that receives the money then
to appoint the person concerned to top
job as I said to Mr Sharp it's all a bit
Banana Republic Banana Republic you
think that's a really is a strong
statement there and of course it matters
because the BBC's reputation hinges on
impartiality millions of people trust it
uses new services do you believe that
BBC is impartial
I think the BBC aims to be impartial
there's always going to be questions
over individual presenters or reporters
but the BBC Prides itself on its
impartiality I'm a former BBC presenter
and youth presenter as you know I was a
newsnite and other programs presented
BBC breakfast and certainly when I was a
presenter nobody ever tried to tell me
what to do what to say or what to ask
that's my personal experience I guess Mr
sharp would say that look with these
bigger public appointments you attract
people who believe in public service and
that's why you get people who have made
donations or are affiliated to parties
right so Mr Sharp has shown no interest
in broadcasting throughout his career
barring one application that he told us
about he previously applied for a job on
the board of the BBC he wasn't even
interviewed to paraphrase Mrs Martin
what was it about this application
following the 800 000 pound facility
that first attracted Boris Johnson to
him as BBC chair is this position
untenable
I don't see how you can carry on how can
he argue the BBC's case how can he talk
about impartiality give them that he
withhold withheld this important
information from us and given the low
levels of trust that he now enjoys
amongst BBC staff
much indeed for your time on the program
well there we go John Nicholson was some
pretty Punchy words shall we say in the
wake of that committee report into the
appointment of the BBC chair
now let's trust's Spirit had returned to
the political Spotlight has
reinvigorated the debate over tax cuts
the former PM's defense of her time in
office has also prompted some of her
allies to double down on their calls for
Rishi sunak and the chancellor Jeremy
Hunt to slash taxes in order to promote
growth we're joined now by the concept
Venture Sir John Redwood lovely to have
you on the program thank you for coming
on this morning now you're a member of
the conservative growth group and we
hear you're developing some policy
proposals to take to the treasury in the
coming weeks what do you want to see
what we want to see sensible targeted
tax cuts that will boost self-employment
boost investment help solve the problem
of recruiting and retaining doctors and
other skilled staff
and we'll add to the idea of growth
we're very pleased that the Prime
Minister and the new Chancellor have now
got growth as one of their big five aims
and indeed out of the five aims three of
the aims are economic and they're all
really related to growth that is exactly
the right thing to do but we're urging
them to do rather more and not to rule
out tax rate Cuts so we think they're
going to be crucial particularly to
boost investment otherwise we're going
to have a very poor year for investment
which will lead to a very disappointing
outturn on growth we've just seen what
the threat of high taxes is doing with
AstraZeneca transferring a very
important investment to Ireland
what specific tax cuts would you like to
see them
well there are quite a lot
um of targeted ones I think first of all
the self-employed getting a very bad
deal I think we should reverse the 2017
and 2021 changes to so-called ir35 you
want to promote more self-employment
make it easier for people to get into
self-employment that is the quickest way
to expand capacity then I think we need
to look at business taxes I don't think
the corporation tax rate increase will
raise the money the treasury in the
overall think it will all the evidence
is in the past when conservative
governments have had the courage to cut
the corporation tax rate never a popular
move it raises more money it's the wage
tax business more than we've just seen
from AstraZeneca what what a big impact
going the other way can have on very
crucial developments in the Life
Sciences area in this case which is one
of the government's targets for
improvement I also think we need to cut
taxes where the tax itself is causing
strain on people's budgets or companies
budgets and it's creating a attack
subsidy Circle Merry-Go-Round which is
very damaging on the Public Accounts and
on the economy and why do we still
impose that on domestic fuel when
domestic fuel is too expensive and then
give people bigger subsidies cut out the
middle man and woman and take the tax
down why do we charge heavy energy using
businesses the highest carbon taxes of
anywhere in the major economies of the
world and then get forced into having to
pay them substance because they're
losing so much money so we need to
remove some of those taxes on energy at
a time of an energy crunch with very
high energy prices
you speak about the tax cuts that we
want to see and I'm just trying to work
out who we is you know how many of your
colleagues agree with you on this
well the the greatest group that is
gathering strength as we speak I think
uh I'm not aware by helping to whip the
growth group but uh and there are dozens
of conservative MPS who take the view uh
that the growth strategy the government
has headlined needs some more positive
measures behind it and I think you'll
find probably a majority of the
conservative back bench would agree with
what I'm saying today that they want
targeted tax cuts and then there will be
a range of views on which the best
targeted tax cuts to choose I think the
majority definitely believes that you
don't get growth without more realistic
tax levels and I think many are very
worried that Britain is in danger of
becoming uncompetitive because of the
higher taxes the government is wishing
to impose and we've had a good record in
past years for making ourselves a bit
more tax competitive if you want to see
what lower taxes does and how it
transforms an economy and increases the
revenues just look across the Irish see
at the Republic of Ireland at the same
time there is a proportion out of
business because they got the lowest
corporation tax of the advanced world
you say if you want to see what low
taxes does you should look at Ireland
but some would say if you want to look
what unfunded tax cuts do you can look
at the last mini budget by Liz truss
where you know the economy was really
wounded by it the bank of England even
had to step in with emergency measures
to stop a run on pensions I mean you
can't surely be proposing to do the same
thing just a few months later
well of course not I don't want to
repeat the mistakes of the bank of
England and the treasury made over that
period but of course sorry I'm just
going to jump in I just want to jump in
because you say there specifically the
mistakes that the bank of England and
the treasury made so you think it was
the bank of England and the treasury who
made the mistakes not the unfunded tax
cuts themselves
well it's very odd idea that some funded
tax cuts at the same time as that tax
change which I think would have produced
more Revenue than the obr and territory
forecasts had we seen them but would
have suggested uh we had double the
amount in extra spending so why don't
you blame the unfunded spending
increases if you think it was deficit it
did it but if you actually look at what
happened in the markets the the bond
market the worried everybody was falling
well before the mini budget statement
for the simple reason that the bank of
England was talking it down the bank
said these bonds are far too high we're
going to sell a load of bonds to get the
prices of the bonds down we want the
long-term interest rates to rise so the
bank of England for policy reasons
decided to sell off the bond market and
then it got out of hand because the bank
of England clearly didn't understand the
precarious position of many Pension
funds including its own pension fund
which was buying far more girls than it
could afford to pay for and that and of
course it rightly stepped in and showed
that it could turn the market on a six
months when it needed to
at the same time though it's the markets
who reacted wasn't it I mean they are
pretty emotionless things the markets
they just look at the what's in front of
them
well the markets on the Monday and
Tuesday when we had the serious sell-off
in Britain that wasn't matched in
America the previous week America had to
sell off the same reasons as well it was
all about the ldi funds and and it
wasn't about quasi quatings mini Budget
on the Monday and Tuesday it was people
saying there is no point in buying bombs
or even holding bombs because
everybody's a seller because all these
funds needed to sell bombs to raise cash
to meet all the margin calls that were
coming in because the bonds have fallen
in price and where you have a lot of
Pension funds that owned four five six
times the amount of bond that they'd
actually paid for they face very big
bills when the price fell so I'm really
interested to talk to you because
obviously it comes after the Liz truss
um piece in the Sunday Telegraph where
she blamed the powerful economic
establishment for what happened you
obviously was the key backer of Liz
trust do you speak to her March what do
you think her take is on the current
direction of the conservative party
well I mean I've obviously read her
essay in the Telegraph and I've had a
chat to us since then
um she does rightly identify the ldi
problems on Monday and Tuesday as being
the main difficulty that we face with
the long-term interest rates she hasn't
gone quite as far as I've just gone
because she could have pointed out that
the bank of England on the Wednesday
showed that not only had it created the
problem but it knew how to solve the
problem very glad it did solve the
problem I agreed with their action I
think they could have done it just by
words they probably didn't have to buy
the extra bonds but buying the extra
bonds made sure that they could get the
market up again and I'm pleased that
they've now told us they've sold those
bonds of
profits went back up I went the One
prices went back up and the interest
rates went back down a bit when the bank
wanted them to and that was the question
um was also about trying to be a little
bit forward-looking as well and I'm just
interested to know what do you think
trust's take is on the future direction
or the current direction of the party
well I suggest you interview less trust
I thought you wanted to know my views on
the economy and I didn't expect some
serious points about how you get growth
and in order to get growth you need to
understand that if you cut certain Tax
Rate rates often the ones that are
unpopular with the left you get much
more Revenue the wage attacks the rich
more is to set tax rates that will make
them stay and pay the wage tax companies
more is to have competitive tax rates so
more companies stay here invest here or
come here and as we saw when um when
Thatcher Lawson for example cut top
rates attacks the rich paid an awful lot
more and more rich people okay okay and
when Osborne cut corporation tax over a
period of years the revenues went up
they didn't fall so my main message to
the the transfer is if you want growth
you have to have lower rates but it
doesn't mean you're short changing the
accounts it means you're finding the
smart way to attach to tax the rich and
tax companies rather more than it is the
rich and the companies of course have
got the money but they don't necessarily
have to pay tax here
the um the polling is pretty Dreadful
frankly for your party right now uh one
uh poll out this week suggested if there
was an election now you've been second
place behind the SNP and of course I
know we have to take these things with a
large pinch of salt but are you
concerned that if your party doesn't
change direction there'll be a Wipeout
of course I'm concerned about the
current polling and it tells you
something about public mood but I think
the public is still with me and being
impatient to get on with the good news
and I think the Prime Minister has
identified the right three main
priorities the the waiting lists the
illegal immigration and the economy and
of the three things you said about the
economy uh the borrowing will come down
if we grow more as a percentage GDP and
inflation is going to come down because
it's a very tough fiscal monetary
squeeze on thanks to recent bank and
treasury action so it's all about growth
and that's why I repeat that you've got
to have a growth strategy indeed that
would reinforce the counter-inflation
strategy why do we have inflations we
don't have enough capacity in this
country why is energy so dear well we're
not producing enough of our own is part
of the reason there are lots of projects
out there that could get us more oil and
gas from the North Sea get on with them
government and set taxes that mean that
people will want to invest there we
obviously need a lot more capacity in
electricity production and routing
electricity around the country again
that this has to be balanced investment
where people can make money get on with
it and you will find lower taxes will
help you do that
okay thank you very much indeed always
uh Keen to hear your own views on this
so good to have you on the program
now we can turn now to a different issue
that I've been Keen to talk about on the
program and it's about violence against
women and girls in just the last few
weeks we've seen these serial rapist and
former met police officer David Carrick
jailed for dozens of crimes spanning
decades in Edinburgh a man was jailed
for killing benlin Burke and her
two-year-old daughter Angelica and
police believe that the head of epson
College Emma Patterson was shot dead
along with her daughter Letty by her
husband now Behind these high profile
stats lies statistics compiled by Refuge
showing that two women are killed by a
current or former partner every week and
police receive a domestic abuse call
every 30 seconds now we're joined by the
women's rights activist Patsy Stevenson
um thank you very much for being on the
program I'm really glad to have you in
this morning I feel like your face is
very familiar to me because I really
remember those images of you at the
Sarah everard protest I think we can see
um you know pinned The Ground by police
I was during covert times that's why
we've got the face mask on
I mean I don't want to go over you know
what happened there but just talk about
why you went on that protest and whether
you think anything's changed since then
well I mean number one it was a vigil
and I you know that's true I shouldn't
yeah no but I mean people do
um you know and before that I was never
an activist I was never a protester
nothing like that I'd never really been
to a protest
um and now I go to protest all the time
I'm in and out of parliament I'm trying
to get rid of bills that are affecting
us you know I'm constantly in this world
now and it's it's strange that was two
years ago and since then we've not seen
any change and this is it's a it's a
massive problem
um where we've got people at the top and
people in the Met police especially
where things happen and then when the
news dies down then promises are they're
empty promises and nothing happens so
you know I don't know what it's going to
take for actual change to happen but
sooner rather than later you know we're
losing people this is this is a real
epidemic you know
epidemic is a word isn't it really is
um part of the reason I wanted to get
you on this because I've just been
reading more and more about the awful
murder of Emma Patterson and her
daughter seven-year-old Epson College
head teacher killed alongside her
daughter her husband George also found
dead but of course the police believe
that he shot them and then killed
himself and you know I just feel like
there's been a lot of talk about a
tragedy about the murder suicide but
it's a murder isn't it that we're
talking about here yeah and again the
problem is you know we've got a lot of
people reporting on it who not only do
people uh people often speculate which
is uh really damaging
um of its own but the headlines you can
find
the onus is always put on women and it's
ridiculous and the thing is that when
you when you post about this stuff I
post about it on Twitter and people are
like I don't see the misogyny if you
don't see the misogyny in this reporting
you might have internalized misogyny
yourself one headline uh did living in
the shadow of his high achieving wife
lead to Unthinkable tragedy I mean yeah
again I mean it's there's no excuse to
murder someone and it is it's again
fear-mongering young women into
believing that not only do they have all
of these other things to worry about men
killing them for if you achieve too much
you may be murdered by your own partner
that's ridiculous now sorry police
originally described it as an isolated
incident now of course you know I know
why they use those words it's to
reassure people that there isn't a
killer at large
um but it's not an isolated as a woman
occur by their Partners all the time
yeah and that's the problem
um I know a lot of women's rights
activists a lot of people that are
speaking up about this stuff a lot of
journalists like yourself that are
talking about this and trying to bring
it to to the public attention and say
listen we have a real issue here where
women are not being taken seriously this
is a real problem that is happening
every single day like you said every 30
seconds they're getting a call you know
and that's that's it's too much it's so
I mean one is too much but this is
ridiculous what kind of world are our
young girls coming into you know um and
I just wish that men would think hang on
this is really happening believe women
and just listen to the women in your
life who are telling you this is really
happening and and try and figure out how
you can help this you know you of course
um we know about you because what
happened and the way that you were dealt
with by the police at as you say a
peaceful vigil it's important to say
um we've seen recently of course David
Carrick had the Met police jailed for
Life over 85 offenses including rapes
and sexual assaults How concerned are
you about the state of Amapola I mean
it's I was concerned like two years ago
and in saying this about the police the
the police system in general needs a
complete overhaul because it's systemic
it's really right hiring women in the
police force isn't going to do there
were women officers at the vigil they're
no better than the Met it doesn't make
you
um you know a better police officer
that's not going to make you not sexist
you can have internalized misogyny
um and yeah so I mean the from what I've
seen of the police
these are just the things that have been
reported on we've got over a thousand
police officers being investigated at
the moment you know Mark Rowley said
that's two or three a week at the moment
and these people their job is to protect
and serve and they're actively abusing
the public when does it change do you
think that it's changing with the new
commissioner Mark Riley who does seem to
be doing quite a lot on this you know
he's giving evidence he's talking about
it he's saying that there's going to be
prosecutions the one thing I will say
about Mark Crowley is I think a lot of
people and I'm not talking for everyone
because I know people say that this
isn't true for them but I appreciate the
fact that he's admitting and holding
themselves accountable however I don't
think he is as serious about it as he
should be because we need change right
now and I think the change that he's
saying will happen is not good enough in
my opinion you're talking a bit about
your own experience with the police what
was it like you know that night
I mean I can't talk much about it
because I'm possibly taking them to
court
um but it's you know for me I
I thought you could never be arrested
unless you do something wrong and that
is not the case that is not the case and
police are known to go to certain
communities and areas where
um you know if they arrest people for no
reason and it sounds far-fetched it's
like why would you arrest someone for no
reason it happens this is a truth
um and they go to these areas because
they can't take legal action against the
police to qualify for legal aid you need
to be earning nothing I didn't qualify
for legal aid and I was a student
earning nothing
um so it's you know there's not enough
help out there for people who are
unlawfully arrested
um and I think the police get a get away
with a lot of things because they're so
close to justices but you're now
considering legal action then is there
anything you can tell us about that or
yeah I mean so I started legal
proceedings
um last year I think it was
um I'm trying to raise 230
000 pounds by March I'm at 17 grand it's
probably not going to happen I'm I'm
hoping
um you know that that we can raise the
money just to take them to court or just
to pursue legal action
um you know I mean if Mark growley or
the police if they if they're doing what
they say they are
I I mean I'm waiting for a response you
know so it's I and it's not just for me
it's for every woman that attended that
vigil I saw what happened they saw what
happened
and the reporting on it you know there
were a lot of people that were reporting
on it and a lot of people did
did show what really happened but the
police got out first and said there side
of the story
and I can tell you now a lot of that
wasn't true
okay thank you very much for being on
the program today it's been great to
have you I've been really looking
forward to speaking thank you thank you
a quick reminder uh before we go I'm
going to prepare on all sorts of things
covered on the show this morning uh we
do have a weekly podcast as well if you
scan the QR code on your screen right
now you can find the safety Ridge on
Sunday podcast And subscribe so it's in
your feed every week so we've got
highlights of all the interviews uh
today a bit of post-match analysis as
well and some insights so do uh check
out that podcast
lots of um really important interviews
this morning about subjects from you
know the earthquake to women's rights so
um a busy program for us but that is it
for this week's super original Sunday in
a minute after the break we're going to
have Liz Bates in the studio our
political cross London running through
what we just learned thanks for joining
us
[Music]